okay guys [ __ ] my [ __ ] controllers
all like crooked hold on all the wires
are all over the place like a [ __ ]
animal okay hello guys we're back we're
back we just jumped this that's right
here hold on the microphones all [ __ ]
up ok and ok ok I'm back I'm back anyway
I love what mission are we all hope
mission are we on the pursuit alright
alright iceplug you and I could do that
I could do that it's not too hard
anyways how's that going down today I
hope you all are happy I hope y'all
living it up I don't deal with any
college after and I would a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] taking me up on my offer
[ __ ] is what the [ __ ] do you want [ __ ]
okay and look the rag it's like down
again yeah that's not supposed to be
here where the [ __ ] am I supposed to be
and I were here again I don't know where
the [ __ ] I'm supposed to go no but up
here we go here we go out now there we
go yes I don't have steady there really
makes it butcher it yet again huh ain't
no doubt about it the thief's get it
back yeah sure use the racket slug in
ass being the barb back na what do you
see borg bunch of [ __ ] there wait
what the [ __ ] oh the racket apology was
like beneath me again forgot you don't
look so good are you feeling all right
now oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] legs I broke them
here we go here we go so I get flag down
[ __ ]
there we go there we go how able to just
go back there what L myself ray I'm glad
you're here I think some of these people
are beginning to suspect who I am are
you ready to face the guild you're about
our solar then we show them down with
your channel remember we have crews keep
your eyes open emotional it's right for
me into the system I hate follow mission
Jesus even if you're one of us better
not make trouble then that booty she
says oh my god I follow up in today
ouch what the [ __ ] keeps [ __ ] at me
absolutely though yeah a pack of that
Billy the hon I gotta just a [ __ ]
microphone okay okay the times are told
his partner I'm sorry good reason to be
here without murderer hey no are you
wasn't so we can speak I have proof that
you've all been miss legs no tricks car
liar or I'll cut you down where you
stand now what's this so-called become I
got the perv honey let me see no it
can't be nah like a fashion of immersive
too long everyone must have been
stealing from the guilty year
there's only one way to find out if what
the last set is cheer velvet I'll need
you to open the vault open about the
other stuff lessons on mystery will see
that book what did he sighs nurse has
been seen from a boat for years Dallas
was looking into it before he was
murdered mega version of Avoca Beach tow
case it's impossible could eat Vicky's
while you that's puzzle locks money
combined no way it can be picked up or
Chioda there use your key on the vault
velvet will open it up and find out the
truth okay
abused 40 but a boat still locked up
tight edited route now usual
I lets say 28 it's gone everything's
gone get in here all you see is that sis
I'm care then [ __ ] the dog just feel
good look [ __ ] okay one sec put it away
right now we can't afford to lose on hmm
calm down we cannot afford to lose our
head that is for sure woody c speaks yes
I don't be right there you do it your
way for now delvin next watch the flagon
if you see Mercer come tell me right
away Riccio light let me get a friend
out before I help you trash no sir down
I need to know what you learned from
Carl I Eliza I mean everyone I'll tell
ya I I feared that was the case from
that lot anything else
what nightingale was there anything else
she told you trying to make Mercer look
was there anything else asked at that
banquet in touch I need you to break
into Mercer's home hi a gift from the
black priors he never stays that just
pays for the upkeep on it hard be
careful not just find a way in get the
information and leave and you have
permission to good question if you can
get past this train watchdog I think
your best bet might be the ramp to the
second floor balcony in his backyard no
I'd wager a well-placed shot at the
ramps mechanism with lure it in honey
careful atmos and I'll tell very odd
that my gamblers had to come back here
my damn Mercer to compassion I'll cut it
off she's a sapphire take it easy I love
Allah Allah Allah
now Joe so I'm like this [ __ ] right
here and [ __ ] prepare to dock oh is this
someone gonna help me
[ __ ] you evolved
oh right after who did this yeah i heard
that that yeah now yeah now [ __ ] egg
go to the front door [ __ ] that [ __ ] our
free outside of the [ __ ] all right well
I got the house k so [ __ ] that huh
God might get nervous barred from the
other side what the [ __ ] let's say let's
say how about [ __ ] give us the only way
in okay I need like a phone error or
something
see the butter map okay weapons Remiel
you can advise everything I've got on
display really come back when you're
ready to swear the weapon greetings
honored friends just what you see here
safe travels Lance driver I'm not your
lab striper fetch come to see salomon
perform miracles will take a look I'll I
if you need any more smithing work come
see me again alright let's shoot down
this [ __ ] can I drag this guy's body
into the water kind of gross there we go
item one single women here let a nutbag
better not back yes I'll go [ __ ] their
ass all up is someone there
I was sure I heard something
there's a [ __ ] here I can like smell
them anybody there you puny weekly I
need to get some good stuff you know to
find cloud no thank you Jess I'll take
that Kyle thank you 8shut
ok it keeps [ __ ] ass with a level of
self love love
keep the kid with a level up when I get
like a scope wine cheese and sweet well
let's sleep well okay before going
upstairs let me just check kosher salt
no thank you suspicious cabinet ah well
done thank you battle snakes again like
it go at the [ __ ]
tamanna pocket I check here
ok ok
perfect man huh anything else get in
here
a rat away ball till [ __ ] I never is he
was always dirty we checked the weapons
real quick that's
yeah that what this says there's that
bad before we begin I want two things to
help me clear one under the real drilled
one rat hole of the media you don't even
care murderous poisoning drug
trafficking in which one job online the
sister a typical typical
there's that [ __ ] yeah
we scoured the town on us Shores beard
he's gone if he gets his hands on them
you can be certain he'll agree he's
taking everything the guild has left and
to go up I've spoken to kar liya and
made amends for how the Guild's treated
her now she quickly we have no time to
lose thank ya